okay all right so now we're going to
talk about probability this what I'll do
in probability today is actually not in
your primer but it is very important and
I use it as a basis for the statistics
so I thought we have enough time to do
that and we'll do that well and then we
will do the statistics later in another
session but everything will do in
statistics is covered in your primer ok
so both probability and statistics are
rigorous ways of thinking about
uncertainty and of course a lot of the
sustainability science or management
that you have to deal with involves
uncertainty in fact almost all of it
does and so probability and statistics
provide a useful tool to handle that
uncertainty and so that's why you need
to get used to it and it should be
actually central to the way you think
even though when we teach many things
both in the sustainability science and
in in management and economics the
uncertainty part comes later usually we
start off with simple examples that
don't have uncertainty that are
deterministic and then we add the
uncertainty but the real world
uncertainty is central it comes before
anything else okay so once you've
learned to walk with the uncertainty you
got you have to get used to
incorporating that uncertainty all the
time you know I've learnt with this
ankle
problem that walking is really just a
series of controlled Falls and and and
you don't realize that after you learn
to walk right you you forget that you're
just falling all the time and so and
that's what I'm certainty should be like
you should incorporate it and you should
realize in your analysis that you're
just making mistakes all the time
everything you say is really probably
wrong but nevertheless you have to
incorporate that it you have to you have
to control your mistakes just like you
control your Falls and that's really
what management is about controlling
that uncertainty okay so this is these
are methods of control we think of a
sample space as a list of possible
outcome so we imagine that uncertainty
and we control it we bound it we
parameterize it a parameter is something
that bounds something like a perimeter
fence those two are etymologically
linked the sample space is a parameter
which bounds our uncertainty in so far
as it lists all possible outcomes that
we imagined for the uncertain set of
outcomes an event is a set of possible
outcome so for example if you think of
the uncertainty as throwing a dice
throwing a die a single die then you
could the list of all possible outcomes
would be one two three four five and six
an event would be a list of possible
outcomes within that list of all
possible outcomes so it might be getting
a number less than three okay so the so
that event would consist of the outcome
one and the outcome to
two outcomes two possible outcomes
adding up to the event getting an
outcome less than three okay relative
frequency is the relative frequency of
an event a is the proportion of times
that event occurs in some fixed number
of trials okay so if I were to throw the
die a hundred times and i were to
compute the relative frequency the
proportion of times in those hundred
trials I got the event a that would be
the relative frequency let's say that
that I got it 30 times out of 100 then
the relative frequency is 30 over a
hundred the probability of event a
occurring is the relative frequency of
event a as n goes to infinity so as I
run that trial repeatedly with no change
in structure except the the new
realizations of the uncertainty the
limit of that relative frequency is the
probability okay okay now there's some
properties of events that we're going to
find useful to talk about one is mutual
exclusivity two events a and B are
mutually exclusive if and only if the
probability of A or B ok and a or b has
a very specific meaning in
probability and that specific meaning is
the probability of A or B is the union
is the probability of the union of
events a and B okay that means either a
occurs or B occurs or a and B occur so
the probability associated with those
three is the probability a or b also
known as the probability of a union B
okay so you've all probably done set
theory in high school or early college
right so this should not be new to you
ok ok if this rectangle represents
that's the sample space that's the list
of all possible outcomes and I have
outcomes hey this is event hey that's a
set of outcomes an event be another set
of outcomes these two events are
mutually exclusive because there are no
outcomes which comprise both event a and
event be right so in that case the
probability of A or B is the probability
of a you could think of it as the area
of this first circle plus the
probability of B the area of the second
circle it wouldn't always be the area if
the probabilities were uniformly
distributed over this space then you
could think of it as area but otherwise
it would be some function of that area
okay but of course events that are not
mutually exclusive might look like this
in that case the probability of A or B
would not simply be the sum of these two
circles because you'd be double counting
the intersection right so by definition
events and B are mutually exclusive if
and only if the sum of their
probabilities gives you the probability
of their union that means the
probability of the intersection is no
okay collectively exhaustive our events
a or b
or C are collectively exhaustive if the
union of all those events is the sample
space or the probability of the union of
all those events is equal to one okay so
the example here would be suppose this
is the set a this is the set B and this
is the set C okay so a B and C would be
collectively exhaustive and mutually
exclusive okay when a set of events are
exclusive they are also known as a
partition of the sample space okay you
can see that a B and C are a partition
of the sample space in casual language
okay and yes ah yes the three line
symbol means by definition okay so
that's the probability of A or B or C is
by definition probability of a union b
union c okay good question okay now a
couple of probability axioms I'm sure
you've met that is if you have a
discrete valued variable X so now I've
gone away from this sort of Venn diagram
and I'm thinking of my uncertainty in
the following structure it is uncertain
in that I have some variable capital X
and it can take on a particular value
little X and I don't know what
value it's going to take on ok so my
uncertainty is that is going to take on
a particular value little X and I don't
know what that is and there's some
probability associated with that value
that random variable capital X taking on
the particular value little X if we're
talking about a discrete valued variable
then it can take on some value one and
two and three and four and five and so
on then I could simply express the
following axiom that is the probability
that X takes on a particular value has
to be less than or equal to one and has
to be greater than or equal to 0 ok
can't be a negative number the sum of
all those probabilities for all possible
values of X has to be equal to 1 is
everyone familiar with this notation
Sigma right over all possible values of
x ok ok here these are the Venn diagrams
which we talked about here we were
talking about mutually exclusive events
now we have two events that are not
mutually exclusive this is the Union a
union B and this is the intersection the
red area is what's being denoted hence
the red lettering is the intersection ok
and now we're not talking about events
which are mutually exclusive so the
probability of a union B or a or b the
probability of a plus the probability of
B minus the intersection probability
right of course if a and B are mutually
exclusive than that 0 ok this is
something how many people have had to
deal with sequel queries
you have right so this is a very useful
thing to keep in mind there is the
concept of the exclusive or the prop in
natural language the word or Never
implies the exclusive or but it
occasionally people confuse it as such
and so this concept is very useful so
this means the exclusive or means either
A or B but not both ok and so when you
do sequel code often this is a useful
query to run and that is the sign for
the exclusive or ok so a couple of
notation things here this is the sign
for the exclusive or this is a or b
which would be this whole area
intersected with the compliments of a
intersection B so this ' denotes
complement and complement is everything
in the sample set that's not in this ok
so if I were to take a intersection B
which is this find the complement of
that that's everything that's not in
this so it's all of that and I were to
take the intersection of that with a
union B then I'd be left with this
exclusive or ok all right let's talk
about conditional probability usually we
care about conditional probabilities we
want to know if something has happened
then what is the probability that
something else will happen for example
there is some probability that it will
rain on a random day
if tomorrow is a random day but if i
told you that tomorrow is a day in april
chances are the probability that it will
be rain will be different we'll probably
be higher than if tomorrow was a random
day throughout the year right april
showers bring May flowers so so there
the condition is that it's April the
conditional probability is that it is
what's up is there probability that
it'll rain given that it's April okay
obviously that's different oh here I had
a more pertinent example perhaps
certainly not more amusing okay so
probability of a tanker spill an oil
tanker spill given that the captain of
the tanker is drunk ok ok so the
conditional probability is given by it
is denoted as follows the probability of
B given a so this line again denotes
given is the intersection probability
divided by the probability of the given
event ok and you can see that of course
okay so probability of a is the
horizontal shaded area and the
probability of a intersection B is the
the cross that what should I call is
there the chequered the checkered area
right so the probability of B given a is
this check it area divided by the
horizontally shaded area okay so it's
this divided by this whole circle right
knowing that a has happened knowing that
the sailor is drunk the probability of
this tanker spill is this / that not
this divided by the whole thing right so
it's going to be higher the conditional
probability is going to be higher in
this case okay suppose a dice rolled ok
an event a is the role takes a value
less than for an event B is that the
roll is an odd number ok what's the
probability of the role being an odd
number that is what's the probability of
event be given that event a has occurred
right so I'm looking exactly for this
quantity probability of B given a well
define the events event a is roll takes
a value less than four so that's one two
or three an event be the roll is an odd
number so that's one three or five
okay so three values that make up event
a one and three these two values are
associated with event be okay so outcome
1 and outcome 3 is in this intersection
okay so the probability of event be
occurring given event a is these two out
of the three possibilities okay this and
this out of the possibilities one two
and three so you know that the
conditional probability is two thirds
but let's just use the formula okay we
want the probability of the intersection
okay so that means events a and B occur
that's the one or the three so you get 1
with probability 1 6 you get 3 with
probability 1 sixth the two are
independent so the sum of these is going
to give you one third so that's
one-third probability of an a is one two
or three well that's just going to be
three outcomes out of six so that's half
so probability of B given a is one third
divided by one half using I must have
given you this formula right as the
formula one third divided by one-half
which two-thirds right yes